So first let's talk about what a dynamic
range is in the real world and
what kind of images we're talking about.
Let's use that to situate our problem.
I'm going to show you a bunch of
pictures that I took all around my house
a while ago.
And again, it was a sunny day so I was
able to capture images under the sun,
but at the same time I was able
to find different dark corners.
And the goal here is to showcase to
you a variety of pictures taken under
different lighting conditions.
So for example this is my first image
where I took basically in a dark corner.
I took it inside,
there are no lights, you know,
kind of,
illuminating any part of that scene.
And even with the long exposure you can
see basically it's a dark image with
nothing there.
Second image I took was
basically again inside, but
with regular inside incandescent bulbs.
You can see a little bit of the scene,
it's a little bit kind of darkish
orangish, reddish kind of
stuff are visible, but
you can see that there's
not much detail here.
Moving up, then we go, still remain
inside, but this time I'm actually near
a window, which basically means that
the scene is now naturally lit.
So there's a little bit
of detail in the scene.
Now you can actually see the character
and the book and everything.
Next one I basically now move
the same two objects outside, but
this time I'm under a shade.
Again you can notice that from going
here the amount of light is increasing.
Finally move to the outside,
now this time under the sun of course,
I've intentionally made it still
that there are no shadows or
anything else like that.
But you can see now the scene is much,
much better lit.
Of course in none of these images
I'm playing around with any
external lighting source like flash or
anything else like that.
Another whole instance would be as
I can now just take the camera and
point it straight into the sun.
Of course the complete opposite
of this dark image here,
everything is just completely bright.
So you notice now that, you know,
there are lots of different types
of lighting conditions, and
the light actually plays a role in
what kinds of images we capture.
And we've discussed this when
we talked about illumination.
But now let's try to understand and
quantify some of this, so we
can understand, what are the different
ranges of light intensity that's
actually in the natural environment
that we're trying to capture?